quand je dis expérimentés je répète dans
la vie je prends une petite fille parce
que j'imagine que vous l'avez vu alors
j'ai précise tout de suite que je
n'étais pas du tout d'accord je les cuis
d'ailleurs dans un article les districts
moi-même avec patrice que j'étais avec
patrice maniglier je veux dire
l'intervention par exemple de la
psychiatre qui est ensuite hissé
dysphorique c'est un peu la personne ne
dise folique la petite fille est d'
historique ou alors c'est que vous
disais tout à l'heure être né dans un
mauvais accord il ya un très bon et ces
deux sociologues france mais qu'elles me
seck il explique très bien qu est ce que
ça veut dire cette idée d'un certain
disons cette façon médical des traités
les transidentité avec cette sordide et
de dire on est dans un mauvais accord et
c'est pas du tout ça on tronçonne n'est
pas né dans un mauvais corps 1 je vais
de la petite fille sasha n'était pas né
dans un mauvais quart d'heure aux
mauvais score c'est ceux qui lui
disaient les frères c'est ce qui tout le
monde lui disait parce qu'ils ne
pouvaient rien faire or prénom les
cadets petite fille s'il aurait pu par
exemple s'habiller en fille est allée à
l'école habillé en fille après on verra
simplement il est oubliée elle est
obligée d'aller à l'école abbey a une
petite fille simplement quand il ya les
tampons du psychiatre elle peut aller
s'il ya les psychiatres qui dit oui et
c'est ces mécanismes là qui empêche
notamment
c'est que j'ai c'est que je dis des
expérimentés et voir qu'elle sait qu'il
sera prêt on n'est pas obligé je suis
d'accord avec vous imagine des deux
filets il ne s'agit pas d décidé les
sexe de l'enfant dès les cinq enfants il
s'agit de lui permettre d essayer à
aider se sentir bien
[Musique]